ladies and gentlemen welcome to this
meeting of licensing
um on the
24th
of
may
my name is councillor jeanette stiltz
and i am chair in this meeting
um
scrolling down trying to find things
have we got any apologies for absence
burner
yes
apologies for ourselves
thank you thank you councillor stevens
has
come today because she thought she was
or she thought she was invited so
she is standing in for councillor
bassinger
disclosure of interest to disclose the
existence and nature of any disclosure
kind of interest other peculiar
interests non-pecuniary interest
interests is relating to items of
business on the agenda having regard to
paragraph
six to eight of the code of conduct for
members members are reminded that they
are also required to disclose any such
interests as soon as they become aware
should the need arise throughout the
meeting members do you have any interest
to declare
thank you
we have the applicant here if you would
like to introduce yourself to the
committee
yeah hello there my name is uh tom
gowans i'm a representative and the
event manager in the park festivals okay
thank you
and would you like to
introduce yourselves as well my name is
james young i'm working with malden
district council and the promoters and
to ensure this year's events run
seamlessly and we learn from
previous events
thank you mr young
my name is greg oliver and we're the
principal noise contractors for the
event
what companies sonic live acoustics
thank you
officers would you like to introduce
yourselves
hello there um my name is daniel winter
i am a licensing officer for chelsea
city council as well as malden district
council thank you thank you
simon welch and i give legal advice to
the committee
thank you very much moving on to agenda
item five which is the application for a
full variation to a premises license in
the promenade park
um
i will call on the applicant to make
a
declaration on
what you want to do and that
okay thank you we wanted to uh vary the
license to allow open hours um between
two and six currently it starts at six
um the actual event that this is for we
plan on opening the doors at four
playing recorded music for one hour till
five and then having the first act on
performing between five and six so
essentially for this particular event
it's just opening two hours early the
reason we want to do this is to stagger
our ingress so that we have we're going
to have multiple lanes at the entrance
and we don't want queues forming after
what happened in manchester okay thank
you
mr winters would you like to
present your report
you chair
good morning
members are asked to consider an
application for a full variation to a
premises license under section 17 of the
license unit 2003 having regard to
representations
receiving the requirement to promote the
full licensing objectives as detailed
below
the licensing subcommittee determines
the application for a full variation of
a premises license taken into
consideration the options that are
available in detailed in paragraph 4.1
below
prominent park is a public open space
owned and managed by morden district
council the application has been
received from mr stephen cochrane who is
the current license holder of in the
park in the prime premises license has
been held by mr cochran since 15th of
june 2021
which authorizes the sale of sale and
supply of alcohol regulated
entertainment and performance of dance
i've detailed the hours and the days
below regulated entertainment and
performance of dance are licensed until
23 30 at 11 30 p.m on saturdays and
until 23 30 it's 10 30 pm on sundays
the complete application was received on
the 31st of march 2022 the proposed
variation is to extend the license plan
hours bringing forward the start time of
the event from 1800 to 1400 on each day
as part of the licensing process a
complete copy of the application was
sent out to responsible authorities for
consultation closing date for
consultation was the 27th of april 22.
the application has been properly made
in accordance with the licensing act
2003 and all procedures correctly
followed the complete application form
is attached as appendix a
the application was correctly advertised
in the locally circulated newspaper
within the time scale allocated under
legislation and on morton districts
council's website
members are asked to note that as this
report is published publicly personal
details has been redacted from some
documents however the licensing
authority and the applicant have
received complete copies of all
documents
during the course of the consultation
period a representation was received
from a member of the public which
referred to the prevention of public
nuisance as listed in section 1.1
a copy of the representation is attached
to this report as appendix b
a plan indicating the location of the
premises is attached as appendix c
to conclude members are advised that
they have the following options when
determining this application they can
either grant the application on terms
and conditions applied for grant the
application on terms and conditions
apply for modified to such an extent as
considered appropriate to promote the
licensing objectives or they can refuse
the application in whole or in part
members are reminded that that the
applicant and or any person making
representation in relation to this
matter may appeal the decision of the
council to the magistrate's court
uh
and that concludes my report thank you
chair thank you mr winters yeah could i
just sorry to i'm just looking at the
application
yeah just
looking at appendix a and maybe mr
winter can
correct me
he knows much more about the procedure
than i do but um
this is an application
to
vary a premises license
um now that that's like a section 34
application of variation isn't it
but this is an application you're saying
under section 17 which is for a new
premises license yeah no i do apologize
that that's correct it's our checks down
to section 34 so that's
now tell me if i'm wrong but
can can you actually make an application
for variation under section 34 when
you're changing the hours of starting
um i have to do my research on section
34 so um because i think
i'm just looking at this now
um when i looked at it
just a little bit before i was looking
at the application and
um
because go to
i'm just going to the application now
application details a page if you go to
page church chair if you go to page 10
um of appendix of the
section 2 of 18.
this this application cannot be used to
very likely so it's extend the period
for which the license has effect
or
to vary substantially the premises so
it's not a problem with the premises
because that's the same but it's
extending the period
by the hours
if you wish to make that type of
change the premises license you should
make a new premises license application
to section 17
um which is
the the where you actually apply for a
new license not actually a variation
so
my understanding i'm not sure i think it
is section 35 or section 36 of the act
is that you can't
apply you can apply for a variation
but it can't significantly change the
premises which this isn't
um
but nor can you change the hours
is that right or wrong
you don't think i'm wrong
okay full variation application allows
the
applicant okay one license to be changed
in effect it's a new
license but it comes under a different
act right because the license is still
present it's still it's a live license
right and a license holder has the
ability to amend that license
uh add in add-in
license for activities extension of
hours or the extension of the license
for area
right under a full variation
right right that perhaps you're
referring to a minor variation yeah i'm
not a full barrier minor variation
doesn't require you can't extend hours
no um or licensed malaria minor barriers
but full variation also known as a major
variation you can can can i i just
wonder uh chair is it worthwhile can i
just have a chat with mr winter about it
so this is procedurally correct could
you adjourn for 10 minutes i can adjourn
this meeting for 10 minutes
just get the law right and maybe mr
winter is correct but i just want to be
sure that you've got a valid application
in front of you thank you and that just
occurred to me looking at it ladies and
gentlemen members of the committee are
you happy for this to be adjourned for
10 minutes
yeah so we will adjourn this um meet him
for 10 minutes to allow
um
mr quelch and mr winters to confer i'm
sure mr winter is right i mean he's
dealing with the area regularly so i'm
sure he's right i just want to make sure
you've got a valid application
and discuss this yeah so
we'll go outside shall we sorry we'll go
outside
we're going to take the youtube
stream off for this 10 minutes okay
thank you
thank you
welcome back ladies and gentlemen to
this meeting of this licensing
variation under section 34.
i will pass over to the
legal officer just to give some
clarification
on this and that we've sought
clarification on some various points
thank you very much chair yeah the the
reason for your german i'm very grateful
for it is so that i could just confirm
with the licensing officer that actually
all the procedures had been followed and
the right sections
uh were being used for this application
and having had
um extensive conversations with him and
with
other licensing officers i'm satisfied
that you can actually everything is in
order and you can proceed with this
application as an application under
section 34 as what's called a full
very application for variation of the
premises license
thank you mr quelch
the members of the public that are
listening and members that are in this
committee we are going to resume this
meeting at 11 16.
mr winters would you like to just give a
quick overview
of what
we are discussing
um
well currently
well currently there is a um
a premises license
um held by morden district council uh
this
we are here uh to discuss an application
for a full variation
of the application and the fact that
we've had a representation received from
a member of the public
and that is for the members to discuss
and make a decision uh whether to
to grant the license
or to to to grant it or to modify the
license or to refuse the application in
full or in part thank you mr winters i
will call upon the applicant do you
would wish to say anything
at this moment in time
and
i don't think i've got anything else to
add other than what i said earlier okay
thank you
members of the committee would you like
to ask any questions
uh yes i do have one question please
thank you chair yes just one quick
question i think it's become apparent
through our um
our conversations outside um chairs just
reminded me to introduce myself it's
emma stevens
i just want to be very clear that this
is an application to extend the hours on
one day only the friday to bring the
start time forward from 6 p.m to 2 p.m
and all other times to remain the same
is that correct please
no no that isn't quite correct so on
this particular event where doors open
at six we'd like to bring the doors the
right doors to open at four so two hours
earlier than the uh the current six
o'clock start time the reason for that
is so that we could manage our cues and
we have a staggered ingress into the
premises so multiple lanes
for searching and scanning um and then
longer trading periods so that we don't
have large queues outside um so that if
there's any terrorist attack the impact
would be lesser because we haven't got
those large queues outside so we're
doing that after what's happened in
manchester recently the reason we're
applying for um on the license for the
hours to be between two and six is uh
purely for the the costs um incurred by
varying your license so i would like to
have the
option if we were going to have an
earlier event sometime in the future
obviously that would have to be agreed
and signed off by um the local authority
and but there wouldn't be any lies and
restrictions going against us so it's
just thinking of the future and um yeah
looking at the costs that are incurred
that's why we're going for the four
hours
and i think what councilor stevens was
asking that is only for the friday
because according to our paperwork
you've got the saturday and sunday
starting at 12. yeah that is correct
that is only for the friday okay lovely
thank you
any other questions
no no no
are you all happy yeah yeah
um
thank you for for the uh long delay and
thank you for coming today there doesn't
seem to be any other questions from the
panel
we will now close the meeting we will go
into private session you will be
notified of our decision within five
working days from today
so thank you very much for coming and i
close this meeting at 11 20.
do you
do you want to give the applicant the
opportunity waiting to hear your results
or would you prefer that they just go
um yeah normally
they go
and then we will let you know
okay so thank you very much thank you
burner
thank you
you